what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and this is the single
biggest and most tragic moment in the
history of the mha manga the manga and
characters from the manga have been
trending worldwide on multiple social
media platforms and people are just
speechless i mean the death flags were
there the foreshadowing was there but i
still can't believe this actually
happened honestly i am in shock and so
is almost everyone else in the mha
fandom well everyone except for nuxtaku
you guys know how this works leave a
quick like and comment to support us in
that youtube algorithm it only takes you
a second but it really helps us out a
lot and if you haven't already make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications it might seem like a small
thing but subscribing helps us out a lot
and it's completely free you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned now for the past
several chapters we have been getting
strong hints that bakugou is seriously
injured and that his life is definitely
in grave danger but i mean that has been
the case before with bakugoyan with many
main characters and two chapters ago he
was pulled to safety by meteo and genus
and that is when the big three took over
the fight against shigaraki and yet even
though genus told bakugo to get off the
battlefield because he can't keep
fighting in his condition bakugou
insisted on staying in fact he began
carefully studying shigaraki's movements
in order to find a pattern so that he
can predict and anticipate his moves in
the future the previous chapter gave us
several important moments and pieces of
information after meteo called out
shigaraki for not having any friends it
was confirmed that tenko shimura is
still in there somewhere within
shigaraki's psyche little tenko was
enraged by meteos statements and he said
that he does have friends like mikuren
tomo and monchan which are all memories
from shigeraki's childhood while he was
still tenkoshimura and before he became
shigaraki this confirms that there are
not only two personalities within
shigaraki's body ai the shigaraki we
know and all for one there is also a
third personality shigaraki's original
personality before he became a villain
tenko shimura this is a worrying
development for the all for one
personality because he wants the body to
become a perfectly melded combination of
him and shigaraki but little tenko
shimura is still in there and that could
put a wrench into all for one's ultimate
master plan the big three then employs
some masterful and highly dangerous
teamwork in order to try and strike a
serious blow against the overpowered
shigaraki after apparently eating an
entire restaurant's worth of food sun
eater turns into that guy from akira he
uses all the food that he ate to create
a massive organic plasma cannon from his
body and he launches a powerful blast
directly at chigaraki now i'm no
physicist so i don't know how eating a
bunch of different foods allowed the sun
eater to create a plasma cannon but i
guess maybe he launched what was
supposed to come out of him some other
way directly at shigaraki instead anyway
sun eater's plasma blast was able to
distract shigaraki long enough for meteo
to hit him right in the face with a
combination of his own strength and
nejida's energy and although this
delivers a tremendous blow to shigaraki
it just isn't enough to take him out
as a shocked and disappointed meteo
negere and sun eater look on shigeraki
tells them to stop being delusional did
they really think that their attacks
could bring down someone whose power
rivals the strength of all might in his
prime shikaraki thinks that the big
three are just not fully grasping how
powerful he truly is and so they are not
just wasting their own time but also his
time and it is at this point that
bakugou steps up to the plate yet again
despite being severely injured bakugou
tells genus to take care of everyone
because they still have a battle to win
as shigaraki approaches bakugou in the
style of a jojo villain bakugo is
suddenly able to anticipate shigaraki's
movements and dodge them with even more
speed than he had ever demonstrated
before it turns out that activating his
new move cluster bomb had several side
effects on bakugou's body that even he
didn't anticipate using cluster bomb
places a tremendous burden on the
nitroglycerin-filled sweat glands on
bakugo's palms and as he kept
accumulating more and more nitroglycerin
spheres in his palms there were just too
many for his palms to handle so these
spheres began dispersing throughout his
entire body in search of an outlet once
the spheres became dispersed throughout
his body they began to detonate allowing
bakugo to reach an unprecedented
explosive level of speed but as a result
his body feels like it is going to fall
apart and yet bakugou knows that this is
exactly what deku has been dealing with
his entire life he has been pushing
through the pain as his entire body felt
like he would fall apart in order to
improve and become stronger as he
continues to fight shigaraki bakugou
asks deku whether he will ever be able
to reach his level of strength and
determination as the fight continues
shigeraki actually finds himself losing
his cool he is even reminded of the
second one for all user who as many have
pointed out looks a lot like bakugou
this is interesting because it indicates
that shigaraki's anger and emotion are
coming from all for one or maybe the
quirk all for one which seems to
remember the second one for all user and
clearly the current fight against
bakugou is leading all for one to
remember the second user for whatever
reason it could be because the second
user looks a lot like bakugou and he had
also gathered allies to fight against
all for one's control just like bakugo
is doing now it could also be because
the second user risked everything and
sacrificed his own life to defeat all
for one just like bakugou seems to be
willing to do right now or there could
be some other connection here there is
of course a popular fan theory that the
second user of one for all is either
bakugou himself who traveled back in
time or it's someone directly related to
bakugou in some way like maybe one of
his ancestors i was always highly
skeptical of the bakugou is the second
user who traveled back in time theory
but with the crazy twist that we just
witnessed in this chapter i'm starting
to become a bit more open-minded i'll
talk more about this later but first
let's get back to the fight we then see
a sort of internal conversation going on
between bakugou and what looks like the
vestige of all might that currently
resides within one for all this could be
just a symbolic representation of all
might or this could be really part of
his vestige that remained within bakugou
due to the events of the second mha
movie either way bakugou says that he
had always meant to ask allmight to
autograph his almighty trading card that
he had bought together with deku when
they were kids due to the circumstances
in which they met bakugo never got the
chance to ask him to sign it but he
always wanted to the very next panel
that we see appears to show a part of
bakugo's body literally bursting apart
under the pressure that he had placed on
himself with all those nitroglycerin
explosions as bakugo's body falls to the
ground the big three and miracle attack
shigaraki at the same time genus rushes
to grab bakugo's lifeless body as it
bounces off the ground and as this
intense scene is happening in real time
we hear a weather report that bakugou's
parents just happen to be listening to
at the same time clouds have appeared in
the skies of the kanto chubu and kansai
regions even though the skies had been
clear just a moment ago and this has
also been accompanied by a sharp rise in
temperature it looks like it's about to
rain and the implication is that this
sudden and drastic weather change didn't
occur naturally we see a brief panel of
bakugou's parents with bakugo's mom
symbolically stating that boy hates rain
we then see the devastated faces of
genus monoma miruko and mirio as
shigaraki declares that the demon lord's
body is now fully realized and that
their story the story in which the
villain is the main character begins
here the final panel is absolutely
brutal and it shows bakugo's dead body
lying next to his almighty trading card
as genius implies that bakugou's heart
has stopped the text on the final page
says the end of dreams and man this is
probably the most heartbreaking and the
most brutal panel in all of mha oh and i
just realized as i'm recording this that
heartbreaking could be considered to be
a pun here but that was not my intention
it is too soon for puns too soon
honestly this is so rough and you know
i'm serious because i actually mentioned
bakugo's mom without even talking about
how hot she is and you guys who've been
watching this channel know that that is
very out of character for me this is
truly an insane and game-changing moment
in mha if this really turns out to be
the end of bakugo then this probably
will turn out to be the biggest moment
in mha period but i still say if because
i feel like bakugo is such an important
character to the story that it seems
crazy to think that horikoshi would kill
him off i mean sure characters like
midnight and sir nidai have been killed
off but they're not even in the same
league as bakugo when it comes to
importance to the story and overall
popularity in fact bakugo has
consistently been the single most
popular mha character according to both
the japanese and the us popularity polls
like he is literally the most popular
character and he has been for years he
is the undisputed fan favorite that is
one of the reasons why i think that
bakugou could still survive this somehow
because having him die like this without
achieving his dream of becoming an equal
to deku just seems so tragic however
horikoshi definitely made it seem like
he was dead it looked like his heart
actually burst open and yes he looks
extremely dead at the moment so reviving
him now without making it look like
cheap plot armor is going to be very
very difficult as upset as many fans are
certainly going to be if bakugou really
dies some fans are going to be equally
upset if he is somehow brought back to
life in a way that feels forced and
unrealistic so if bakugo somehow
survives how could that happen if his
heart has stopped how could he possibly
come back to life one option is that
eddie or someone who can use rewind for
whatever reason is able to use rewind on
bakugou before he clinically dies but
that is a long shot because why would
little arie appear on such a dangerous
battlefield all of a sudden but if we
are going with arie or someone else uses
her wind on bakugo then i wonder if ares
rewind can actually send people back in
time maybe that is what actually
happened to eddie's father he was sent
back in time but she doesn't realize it
and she thinks that she reminded him out
of existence so if arie is able to
accidentally rewind people back in time
maybe she really could do the same thing
to bakugou so bakugo's bodies are wound
back to life and back to a point where
he is not critically injured but he is
also accidentally sent back in time to
the era of the second one for all user
and he becomes the second one for all
user this would be a somewhat plausible
way of actually making that bakugo as
the second user theory happen but this
would be such an insane and out there
twist that i just don't know if
horikoshi would be willing to go that
far and this would also mean that while
bakugo is not technically dead he has
been sent back in time so he can never
see his parents or his friends ever
again another possibility for how bakugo
could survive that is not related to
rewind is related to nitroglycerin
itself just as i'm not a physicist i am
not a medical doctor so i can't confirm
any of this but people have been saying
on social media that nitroglycerin is
often used in heart medication and that
it can even be used to shock a heart
that has stopped back to life so maybe
bakugou's nitroglycerin will be able to
somehow shock his heart back to life
even if it has stopped
maybe but the one quick panel that we
got to see of bakugou's heart or at
least what looked like bakugo's heart
seemed to indicate that there was actual
physical damage that the heart had
suffered if that's the case then this
may not be a situation where his heart
can just be shocked back to life if
there is serious physical damage to the
organ then the damage has to be repaired
somehow before the heart can start
beating effectively again man what an
absolutely crazy chapter and you better
believe that bakugou has been trending
worldwide on twitter and other social
media nakstaku is once again being
hailed as the troll prophet of mha the
shippers are absolutely losing their
ship and the rest of us are wondering
where the story will go from here and
we're thinking about the absolutely
massive impact that this is sure to have
on deku and the other hero students i
need you guys to comment right now do
you think that bakugou is really dead or
can he somehow survive this
i'm not even kidding even if you've
never commented on one of my videos
before you need to comment on this one
personally i am extremely torn about
this whole situation on the one hand i
think bakugou is too important to die
but on the other i struggle to see how
he can be brought back to life at this
point without having it seem like cheap
plot armor if you were the writer of
this story and you had to come up with a
good way of having bakugo survive how
would you do it comment down below if
you guys enjoyed this boku no hero video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps me
out a lot and of course if you haven't
already please take the time to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications it is a
quick and completely free way of
directly supporting the channel and here
on youtube that means a lot you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the toasted chi corey mcgowan big
buddhist and jeremy pontier and i can't
forget all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor fat boy games
kaido might be a duck alivania and anime
s codem if you guys enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon or
here through youtube memberships even a
single dollar helps and it means a lot
to us as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys